we're happy when our expectations of how
our life is supposed to be going are met
and from that you can deduce we're
unhappy when our expectations of how our
life is supposed to be going are unmet
so my expectations equals the
billionaire in Mayfair getting a medium
rare steak when that was what she or he
ordered and my expectations would be he
ordered or she ordered medium rare and
it came I had no bloody like unmet
expectations you get unhappiness and you
go to Botswana where I was born hot bowl
of rice expectations met the objective
situation matters less than the
subjective meeting of expectations unmet
expectations in work in your team
members in your relationship in yourself
will result in unhappiness